Good morning. We hereby reconvene the March 2022 meeting of the State Board of Education.
And Brooks, can you please call the roll to reestablish the quorum?
Good morning. Member Bonanca?
Here.
President Darlin-Hammond?
Member Escobedo?
Here.
Vice President Glover-Woods?
Member Lewis?
Present.
Member McQuillan?
Member Olken?
Present.
Member Roscoe-Gonzalez?
Member Petillo-Brownson?
Here.
Member Rodriguez?
Present.
We have a quorum.
Terrific.
We are going to be having a public hearing.
And I want to describe the way in which members of the public can dial in for public comment.
You should view the live stream of the meeting to know at what time we will ask for public comment for each item on the agenda and for the hearing.
Public comment will be provided by dialing the phone number and participant access code and then following each of the operator's prompts.
Upon dialing in, callers will be added to a caller queue.
The operator will notify callers when it is their turn to provide public comment.
We will also ask the public calling in for public comment to please turn down the speaker volume of their computers if they're following the live feed in order to avoid an echoing effect.
Public comment is limited to one minute for each speaker per item.
Item 13 is the general public comment item during which members of the public may provide comment on matters that are not specifically listed on the Board's agenda.
Board members, please mute your microphones when not speaking and keep your cameras on as much as possible to ensure that we maintain a quorum throughout today's virtual meeting.
For each item on the agenda, there will be an opportunity for Board members to raise your hand using the Zoom participant window if you'd like to ask a question or make a comment.
Item 11 is where we're beginning today.
Item 11 is a public hearing regarding the Eagle Collegiate Academy.
And this is to consider revocation of the charter pursuant to California Education Code 47607H.
And the CDE recommendation is that the State Board hold a public hearing on March 10th to consider the final decision to revoke the charter.
If the State Board finds sufficient grounds for revocation, the Department recommends that the State Board adopt the final decision to revoke Attachment 1
and that the State Board provide notice to the ECA Board, the Eagle Collegiate Academy Board, that revocation becomes effective on Wednesday, March 30th, 2022.
If the State Board takes action to revoke the charter, the CDE recommends that the State Board direct Eagle Collegiate Academy to immediately begin the closure procedures set forth in the ECA charter.
This item will be presented by Stephanie Ferland of the CDE.
Stephanie, you may begin.
Thank you.
Good morning, President Darling-Hammond and Board members and Chief Deputy Mary Nicely.
As President Darling-Hammond mentioned, today consists of the California State Board of Education holding a public hearing and considering the revocation of the Eagle Collegiate Academy charter.
The CDE's recommendation today is that the SBE adopt the final decision to revoke and that the SBE provide notice to the Eagle Collegiate Academy Board that revocation becomes effective on Wednesday, March 30th, 2022
and direct ECA to immediately begin the closure procedures set forth in the ECA charter and memorandum of understanding between the SBE and ECA.
Just as a reminder, we went over this yesterday, but the grounds for revocation for California Education Code 47607F is that a charter may be revoked if substantial evidence indicates that the charter school did any of the following.
Committed a material violation of any of the conditions, standards, or procedures set forth in the charter.
Failed to meet or pursue any of the people's outcomes identified in the charter.
Failed to meet generally accepted accounting principles or engaged in fiscal mismanagement.
Violated any law.
The CDE has provided substantial evidence that ECA engaged in fiscal mismanagement, committed a material violations of the charter, and committed violations of law.
The CDE outlines the specific violations committed by ECA in item five of yesterday's meeting agenda.
So the summary is that the CDE concludes that there is no fiscal viability for ECA moving forward.
Based on the CDE analysis, the CDE estimates that ECA will have an estimated negative ending cash balance of over $480,000 and a negative ending fund balance close to $600,000 by June 2022.
ECA will fail to meet its financial obligations, including but not limited to staff salaries, pension obligations, and benefits by May 2022, and payments beginning in July 2022 will be offset to recover any remaining LCFF overpayment.
The CDE has communicated with the districts of residence for ECA's current students, as well as the Los Angeles County Office of Education.
All are prepared to help ECA's 12 students transition to other educational options within their area.
In conclusion, the CDE recommends that the SBE take the following actions.
Adopt the final decision to revoke the ECA charter and provide notice to the ECA Board that revocation becomes effective on March 30th, 2022.
Direct ECA to immediately begin the closure procedure set forth, as stated earlier, in the charter and the memorandum of understanding between SBE and ECA.
The public comment slide is on the screen.
And that's it for my presentation this morning.
I believe you're on mute, President Darling-Hammond.
Thank you.
I hereby open the public hearing at 8 37 a.m.
We will first hear from representatives of ECA.
They will have 12 minutes to make their presentation.
After the presentation from the school, we will open up the phone line for public comment from individuals who are not part of the school's presentation.
Dr. Akoya Johnson, you may begin.
I'm not hearing you.
I'm seeing a slide.
I had to unmute.
All right.
And now we are not seeing the slides yet.
Yes, I have to start sharing it again.
Okay.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
I just want to go to play from start.
Yes.
Okay.
Now let's come back.
Screen.
Good morning, Madam President of the California State Board of Education, Dr. Darling-Hammond.
Good morning, honorable State Board members of education.
Good morning, CDE staff.
And I thank you again for hearing us today.
Today I would like to spend time going over the fact that we have received some additional pledges that we shared with CDE that were not included in the results and the reports that they presented.
And so we believe that the notice was sent, but that it included facts that were outdated and that CDE omitted all the recent facts and recent responses that we submitted to them.
And one of them is that we received $530,000 in pledges.
And this is enough to be able to repay the LCFF overpayment, provide the required budget reserve, and thereby eliminating all the fiscal solvency alleged violations.
If you look at that slide in front of you, you would see the items in bold.
With the $530,000 pledges that we received, we would have $85,431 as a net surplus for 2021-22.
We would have a fund balance of $65,087, and we would have a fund balance as a percent of expenses with the $530,000 at 7.06%.
Our team worked really hard with the fundraising campaign that we did, reached out to different groups, and some are still sending us funds to help us keep this school open.
And so as a result of that being the fact that this is the main concern, we believe that we did provide evidence to show that we can be fiscally solvent, but this was not shared and was not reported in the CDE response.
As a result of that, we are showing as well that the facts that were included about the facility did not include the Caltrans information showing that the site has been cleared.
It omitted the fact that our future site has received a Los Angeles County Regional Site Plan approval, which will allow us to begin the process of placing modulus on the site.
We did not continue with that route because CDE required us to find a place we can use right away, and so we went to the church site.
It omitted the floor plan that shows, and this floor plan was reviewed by the California Los Angeles County Regional Planning, Building and Safety Department, and showed the occupant load for it to be used to be up to 76.
That was not shared.
So we believe also that the information about the non-classroom program was also not updated.
The facts are outdated because once we have a facility to use, then that will eliminate the non-classroom based alleged violations.
And we remain confident that we have already addressed the Independent Study Written Agreement alleged violations.
We also show that in terms of enrollment, the information is also outdated because it doesn't show the response that we submitted showing that we have received substantiated registrations that could be used for this school year as well as next school year.
And we're not sure why CDE keeps not adding this information and creating the false impression of any intent on our part not to provide them accurate information.
They know that we make projections, and then they know that we also have to show them who walked down through the door when the school opens.
So as a result of that, we are asking you to please deny the notice of intent to revoke.
We are asking and we are requesting that ECA be allowed to use the Crown Church facility that has been prepared for the students, which has been cleared by Caltrans,
to enroll more students for this school year and to be allowed to complete the remaining five-year term since we have already received 92 applications that could be substantiated for the 2022-23 school year.
We believe that if allowed, we should be able to enroll students again for this school year.
However, should CDE, should SBE, I'm sorry, decide that you would not allow us to continue and that you would go ahead and revoke this charter and deny our students the opportunity to continue,
we are then requesting to surrender this charter as of June 30, 2022 for the following reasons.
We implore your humanity and ask you that you please heed the askance, the pleas of our families and students who have requested and are asking to be allowed to finish out this school year
so that they will not have to be pulled during the middle of the year, which will devastate and disrupt their lives.
We are asking for the students to be allowed to use this facility, which they've been promised for so long,
which we spent considerable time, the families came to put it together, to set it up so that they will be ready for CDE to review.
We do have, contrary to what CDE keeps saying, enough funds to be able to finish out the school year and meet all our obligations.
So for that reason, we're asking for you to please allow us and allow the students to reach the end of the school year should you decide to revoke and then allow us to be able to surrender the charter by then.
Here is the site draw that I was not able to show you yesterday of the current site, the way it was set up, so that you can see that it's really ready to go.
The Caltrans has now cleared it and showing that there is no reason why that can be a viable school site for us.
And it's been set up so that students can use this site and the students and their families were very excited when they came to visit this site and couldn't wait to get in and just start learning.
And it has room and enough space for all the students that we currently have and will have.
And a playground for them as well.
And then as for the next school year, we also have a slide to show you of what we plan to provide our students using the modular classrooms.
The Los Angeles County Department of Regional Planning has approved our site plan review process and we are ready to begin to be able to place modular classrooms here, which is the next phase and we have plenty of time to be able to accomplish that.
Again, our families were looking forward to this site and we're looking forward to starting their new year at this site with the modular buildings that you're watching right now during this tour.
So we do have a place for us to be able to start next school year and we have a plan to be able to do that.
We continue to conduct a vigorous enrollment campaign using paid enrollment companies that know what they are doing in addition to our own efforts of door to door knocking.
We know where our families are.
We have spoken to them.
You have heard them and we are asking you to please, please allow us to finish what you allowed us to start.
We have been trying to get, do everything that CDE has asked us to do.
We have reached out to them to ask in emails that can be substantiated what they need us to do to make this happen.
We generally don't get any response back or we get nothing saying that we could move this forward.
So we have shown the desire to work with CDE to do what they've asked us to do.
And we continue to show that desire.
If you allow us to continue to serve our students and our families and to provide for them this education that they have themselves, they themselves have shown that they are happy with.
And we want to be able to serve more families who are really ready for this to happen.
If you let us.
Thank you.
At this point, we will open the phone line for public comments and we will need the public comments slide displayed.
Members of the public wishing to provide comment on this public hearing may do so by calling the telephone number and using the access code provided on the slide that will be shown momentarily.
I'm going to pause and wait for the slide.
It may be that.
Dr. Koya Johnson, would you mind stop? Thank you so much.
OK, members of the public, we encourage you to please state your name and affiliation for the record when you call in.
There is the telephone number and the participant access code.
Turn down the speaker volume of your computer if you are following the live feed and speakers will be limited to one minute each.
We also ask, as always, that callers be respectful.
Comments at this time must be related to the item before the board at this time.
Are there any public comments?
Yes, we have about 19 people signed up for public comment.
I will open the phone line now.
Caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Hello, can you hear me?
We can.
OK, my name is Adison and I'm the Director of Charter Services for the Actinagua Dulce Unified School District.
I'm here in support of the revocation of Eagle Colleges Academy Charter School.
We work collaboratively to hold operating procedures of our charters at high standards and accountability.
Eagle Colleges Academy has in the past four years made four unsuccessful attempts to obtain approval to establish a charter school within the Actinagua Dulce boundaries.
A great concern to our district has been the charter's consistent inability to give assurances of the appropriate operating requirements for the school.
Inability to provide reasonable enrollment numbers and inability to provide financial plans that do not rely heavily on aggressive initial enrollment and growth to cover its projected expenditures.
Providing additional fiscal support, facilities, and time will not rectify the inherent deficiencies that have been consistent from years with planning and the implementation of Eagle Colleges educational.
Thank you, caller. Your time is up.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Yes, my name is Gene Stabe. I'm a local pastor here in the Actinagua Dulce area and I am in support of the Eagle Collegiate Academy.
The staff and the administration are excellent. I like the program that they have and it's needed here in our community.
I've been in here this community for over 22 years. The teachers are the best and go the extra mile.
I've witnessed students and teacher interactions and they're well behaved and eager to learn.
And so I just wanted to say this would be wonderful to see them continue to meet here in our community.
And I know they have a facility that's available to them. So I really encourage you to consider them and continue to keep them open. Thank you.
Thank you. Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Hi, good morning. My name is Ejike Makoye. I'm a father of two children. My kids go to school at Eagle Collegiate Academy.
I'm begging on behalf of them for not shutting down the school because the teachers have a great program for the children.
Since my kids started going to that school, they've been doing good in the academic and they really love going there.
Are we praying for us to continue letting our children go into this school?
Please don't shut down our school. We need it so we can be smarter or we just don't know how to do things that much.
We have to learn things. If we don't have the school, we won't learn things.
And we won't be able to get real school. We just have to go online school. That would be sad.
Thank you, caller. Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Good morning, caller. Please state your name and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now.
Okay, moving on. Next caller, please state your name and affiliation. Your time starts now.
Hello, my name is Jolie. I'm a mother of two kids at ESCA and I'm here to support them.
My kids are really happy with the school. They have been learning so much. The staff, everybody has been so supportive for my kids.
I mentioned this to them last night about closing school and they got really sad and I'm really worried about them emotionally because they're really happy with the teachers.
So I would like you guys to consider this, to leave the school open. I know it's going to be a great opportunity, not just for the kids but for everybody, for our community.
I mean, there's so much to say about this school and I'm really happy. I'm really thankful for this school, for everybody.
So please consider this and please leave the school open. Give them the opportunity to become somebody, some special kids and people in this community.
So consider this call, consider this message and thank you so much.
Thank you. Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Yes, my name is Whitney E. Banks. I was looking to enroll my son for the next coming year into this school. Once I saw the curriculum they offered, it's really unmatched in terms of what the other schools in the area are offering.
I was super excited. The idea of smaller classrooms plus being able to have after school care is like beyond needed, especially with folks like me trying to get back out here, get back into work.
And you know, we need that extra help with the after school care. A school like this, it's a shame that it doesn't have a chance to really get off the ground.
If there are small things that can be rectified, it will be awesome. If you guys could just lay it out clearly, give a reasonable time frame and allow the school to actually have a chance to thrive and succeed.
During a pandemic, everything is upside down. The school, you know, from my understanding, kind of started in the midst of all that. It really should be given a fair chance. Education is important and it should be top priority in this country.
Thank you, caller. Your time is up.
Am I shooting it down like this?
Thank you, caller.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now. You have one minute.
Jeffrey Forrest, board member with Eagle Collegiate Academy, and I'm calling to ask that you give generous consideration to allowing Eagle Collegiate Academy to continue to deliver the kind of excellence and educational stewardship that it has done since it's found.
Yes, it is struggling, but if you go back in history, many of the schools that originally opened throughout our country often had the same exact struggles that Eagle Collegiate Academy have had.
I believe that given this opportunity, we will see that this specific school will provide the kind of equity and access that many of our students who are struggling from communities of color desperately need.
Thank you, and we appreciate your consideration.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Good morning. My name is Ken Higginbotham, president, board of directors for Eagle Collegiate Academy.
It is imperative that you allow this exceptional institution of learning for these children and in some cases in underlying areas to have the education that they deserve.
You know, if you shut it down right now, you are depriving all of these children and the family of the opportunity to excel.
You've heard the comments and you've heard the statements made that are totally, totally justifiable.
I highly encourage you allow us to move forward and provide better students, which are better citizens. Thank you.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Good morning. My name is Dawn Hakeem, and I am calling to voice my support for Eagle Collegiate Academy.
There is not another high performing, high test score charter school in this area.
And not only that, the opportunity to be in a primary year's international baccalaureate program, this is something that these kids will benefit from for a lifetime.
I please urge you, beg you to consider giving us a chance, letting us get into a location and then see how it goes because there are so many people working behind the scenes with passion that I am confident it will be a success.
Thank you for your consideration.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Good morning. This is Jack Ritter, and I just ask you please provide the ability to use the approved facility to help us finish out the year and not stop the student's development and thus allowing the school the opportunity to enroll more students.
I just hope that you think about the students. Thank you for your consideration.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Hi, my name is Ashley Cussell. I am the second and third grade teacher at Eco Collegiate Academy, and I just want to please ask you to please help ECA and please allow them to remain open.
These students will be devastated if the school closes. They're doing so well. They're learning so much, and the idea of having them have to start at a brand new school in the middle of the year is so heartbreaking for them.
I ask that you please allow the school to continue and to allow these families to get the chance to get their students into a school that is now in person and that is basically everything that these students have been dreaming of and these parents have been dreaming of.
Please do not shut the school down, and if there is a chance that it has to be shut down, please let the students stay till the end of the school year. Don't have them have to uproot their lives in the middle of the school year. They're doing so well.
Please think about the children. Thank you.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Caller, you're live.
Go ahead.
Yes, thank you so much.
My name is Eliana Howe, and I'm here to voice my support for ECA.
And basically, I know this is a brand new school, and it's just everything that the parents have been dreaming to have in this area is going to be as new as possible.
I think that the parents have been dreaming to have in this area is going to be a nice safe location for them to send their children to, and they will have an after school program.
And it's just an amazing academic program they have going.
Also, I have been there myself, and I think it's an amazing place.
And also, I have seen the students in the classroom, and they are doing amazing.
Please keep the school open. Thank you.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Hi, good morning. My name is Johanna Chavez, and I'm a mother of second grade students.
I'm asking you please to support ECA, and consider it to be open.
I see in our Dulce we don't have too many schools, and I applied for I leave once, and my kids still in the waiting list.
And I see the other schools that are closest to me is in action, and it's a little bit hard for me because I have another busy middle school.
And please give a chance to have another option in our area. Thank you.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Hi, my name is Ruth Posey, community member. I'm calling to support Eagle Collegiate Academy.
At this point in the school year, I think it would be unfair to the children and the families to interrupt instruction.
The kids and the families deserve to go to this school, and the kids definitely deserve to continue learning and thriving with their classmates and teachers.
So please consider keeping the school open. Thank you.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Hi, my name is Kristen, and I support Eagle Collegiate Academy.
Please consider keeping the school open for the children and the community.
Again, it would be sad and a shame to close the school down, especially in the middle of school year.
The school has a great education program, and it's good for the community. The teachers, the staff, and the students are doing well.
Please don't shut the school down. Thank you.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Hello, my name is Isabella, and I support Eagle Collegiate Academy.
I support their mission and their values, their strong core values.
I see how caring and dedicated the ECA staff is to one another, especially to students and families.
And I know that my children will receive a quality education.
So I ask that you please consider keeping the school open for the children, especially the students of color and the community,
because of the rigorous education that is not widely available in the community, especially in the International Baccalaureate Program
and the multiple languages, Korean and Spanish, not really seen in this community.
And it would really help if you keep it for this year and for the next year if they are in person and they experience ECA as it should be, as it is.
Thank you, caller.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Hi, my name is Brandi Ervin, and I am a mother of a pre-K student at ECA, and me and my family support this wonderful school and the staff and administration.
We are more than dedicated to this school. My daughter has been thriving and learning and just loving everything that ECA has to offer.
I believe that if we're able to get this school open and let the kids really come in and experience what this developmental plan and all the things that they have to offer the kids,
it can really go really far, and I'm more than certain more parents will come and really be able to see what ECA has to offer and more students will be able to be a part of this wonderful program.
So please leave this school open. Give them a chance. Let us open up. Let our kids really experience all the great academics they have to offer. Thank you.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Good morning, State Board members. My name is Lorraine Richards, and I am a classroom teacher representing California Teachers Association.
CTA supports the CDE's recommendation that the State Board adopt the final decision to revoke the ECA charter.
As stated by my colleague yesterday, the issues that CDE outlined in the item are egregious and led to ECA being overfunded by almost half a million.
ECA's shifting attendance actions are reminiscent of the A3 scandal, and we believe it would be prudent for the CDE to investigate ECA's actions to determine if it was growth mismanagement, growth incompetence, or fraud.
As educators, we are deeply committed to the success of each student.
That is why we urge the State Board to send a message that these types of actions will not only be punished via revocation actions, but also with legal actions whenever warranted. Thank you.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Good morning. My name is Uza Makamadziski. I'm just asking the Board to allow ECA to be opened and not to close it.
I beg you guys to please allow them some time to put in place everything that is required of them, because the school is exceptional.
They offer good curriculum, and kids there love everything about the school. So please think about the children and let the school remain open. Thank you.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Hi, my name is Anna Ward. I'm a parent of a third grader, Andrew, and I please ask that you continue to have Eagle Community School open.
My son has been thriving, and I wish that you could give him an opportunity to soar in an interesting environment.
He was a home school child. He has been thriving in this environment, and I believe that if you take this away from him, he will take back steps into what he was a couple of years ago.
So I really plead that you continue to give him an opportunity. It just sunk in in his brain that his school might be closing, and he was not happy. He was very upset in learning that his school might be closing. Thank you.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Caller with the last four digits of the number 6831, you are live. Please start your public comment now.
Okay, moving on. Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Hello, my name is Jenny Gonzalez. I'm a parent of a third grader. His name is Jaden Gonzalez, and this morning he was very upset, and he's like, mommy, we need to call because I don't want my school to be closed.
I believe that they need an opportunity to have a physical building and to build more relationship with their peers as they're being doing now through the computer. There's an excellent chance for growth. Please give us the opportunity. Don't close the school. Thank you.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Caller ending in the last four digits, 1-0-0-0. Please start your public comment now.
Okay, it looks like nobody is on the line. That concludes public comment for item number 11.
Thank you very much.
At this point, with no further public comments, I'd like to close the public hearing at 9-10 a.m., and we will now begin board discussion.
And I'd like to ask our liaison, Vice President Glover-Woods, if she would like to make some initial comments.
Thank you, President Darling-Hammond.
I'd first like to just reiterate my appreciation for all of the callers that called in today for public comment, the students, the families, the staff of Eagle Collegiate Academy, as well as others who have voiced their thoughts and ideas.
I do want to underscore something that I said on yesterday, which is my ongoing concern for the fiscal viability and solvency for the school.
I have a few clarifying questions that I'd like to ask when we open up for discussion, and I will hold my questions until other board members have a chance to ask as well.
The last point that I'd like to make before we go into our discussion is the acknowledgement of the school districts in the area and the Los Angeles County Office of Education who have indicated that they will be assisting any families should the board decide to revoke the charter during this school year.
They will be in assistance to quickly ensure that any students enrolled in Eagle Collegiate Academy are enrolled in a local school area per what is wanted and decided by their families, so I do appreciate that as well.
At this time, President Darling-Hammond, I will hold my additional comments and my questions until my fellow board members have opportunity to ask and discuss as well.
Thank you.
All right.
While I'm looking for, please use the raise hand function to let me know if you want to make a comment.
Member McQuillin.
Thank you, and I want to thank all the callers for calling in also to try to support their school.
I appreciate all the callers.
I have a clarifying question if I can ask.
Please do.
In the report from CDE staff, we heard, I think I heard 12 students were attending in November, and it sounded like most of the learning was occurring online, and is that still the case this month of March?
Do we know?
It is.
Thank you.
We have Member Lewis and Member Escobedo.
Member Lewis.
Thank you, President Darling-Hammond, and thank you for Dr. Johnson for the presentation and also for the callers.
I just have a clarifying question and then just one initial question.
ECA talks about the acquisition of the $530,000 in pledges, and we have the concern about ongoing fiscal, meeting those fiscal obligations.
And so going forward, I mean, we have to look beyond this year and into future years, and I think Vice President Glover Woods answered my question, but I just want to ask straight out.
We are still concerned about fiscal responsibilities and the charter being able to meet those going forward.
Am I correct?
The $530 in pledges would just help them take care of obligations in current year?
Is that correct?
It is.
We don't have any.
The information about those pledges came in, actually, while I was presenting yesterday.
So we don't have anything formal in terms of the pledges or whether these pledges can be verified, that sort of thing.
But given even giving the school the benefit of the doubt that they certainly can get these this this money, typically what the department does is they don't include soft money in in budgeting analysis just for the reasons that you outlined Member Lewis.
And yes, even if giving them the benefit of the doubt and that they would be able to receive this money from the pledges, they would still be in the red at the end of the school year.
And it would and yes, it would not dig them out of out of the fiscal hole that they're in.
OK, thank you for that.
Thank you for that.
And if I could, I have one more question, please.
The your suggestion or request to extend the closure date to June 30th.
What fiscal impacts would that place on them or or additional fiscal impacts or or deficits?
I guess if we extended it to that day, if that was even considered.
Right.
Well, based on our analysis, they will not have enough money to make it to the end of the school year.
And so I'm not sure and I'm sure Judy Sias can can weigh in if she needs to, but I'm not sure what the liability is for the board or the department if they do run out of money and cannot pay their expenses and their teacher salaries and retirement benefits and all of that that goes along with that.
But our analysis shows that they will not they will not be able to sustain through the end of the school year.
It's not wanting to close the school in the middle of school year is not something that you would want to do unless there was no other option.
Thank you.
Judy, did you want to weigh in on that?
Yes, Judy Sias, Chief Counsel for the State Board.
Based on CDE's projections, they will run out of money in May.
Again, as Stephanie testified yesterday, there are some concerns about whether or not they will have sufficient funds to meet their obligations for staff salaries, staff benefits, health and health benefits, as well as pension benefits.
In the past, there has been some question about liability.
Should pension benefits not be made?
Whether it falls onto the county office of education or the state.
So it gets pretty complicated when the pension obligations are not met.
And obviously, when staff salaries and benefits aren't able to be met, that also can create quite a few problems for the school and the staff.
Thank you.
Member Escobedo?
Actually, that was one of my comments is, you know, they have 4.5 FTEs with 12 students and the expenditures even and if they obtain a school site, the expenditures then will increase even further, will increase further and the gap will just widen.
So my understanding there has been no attempt in decreasing expenditures or increasing revenues, is that right, Stephanie, and that they will lose, they will run out of money by May.
That is our analysis and you're correct and I'm sure member Glover-Woods can attest to this.
This was a conversation that the ACCS also had during their discussions in terms of the number of staff they had for the small amount of students and whether they've made the appropriate reductions in expenditures for what they have and we have found that they have not.
And typically when a charter is closed, we liquidate assets and my understanding there are no assets at this point.
They don't own a facility and they don't have much left in their bank account.
And so there wouldn't be too many assets as far, I mean, we really need to do a total review of it, but I don't think there are many.
Thank you.
Are there any other questions or comments from members of the Board?
Member Patio-Bronson and then go ahead, please.
I just want to appreciate all the callers who voiced their concern and also appreciation of what the school has provided thus far and also recognize that I think that the leaders of the school and the teachers have had the best of intentions, have tried to bring forward something that is innovative and responsive to the opportunity to grow something new and exciting.
And also at the same time recognize that part of running a school system is more than that and it requires a level of oversight of the finances and the facilities that we just aren't seeing and I do think there have been multiple
Outreaches to the school to try and help them cure some of these challenges, but we have a fiduciary responsibility as board members to actually ensure that it is not just innovation, but it's innovation that can actually live within the bounds of a public use of funds.
The one question I did want to ask
and a number of callers I think reference this is if you can just talk a little bit more about what the options are for families as they navigate what happens at the end of March 31st.
In part, it seems like there might be some misinformation as to what
families believe their options to be that they have to do online only as their only resource or option and if CD folks could talk to that.
Certainly, so we have determined the districts of residence for all of the 12 students who are currently enrolled in ECA.
We have reached out to each of the districts where those students reside and have gotten written confirmation from each of those districts that they are ready and willing to place students in classroom based instruction if that's what they choose immediately.
We've also received written confirmation and you heard from Los Angeles County Office of Ed yesterday that they are also ready to work not only with the districts and helping them place students, but with the families themselves for any district programs or any charter also if they want to remain in a charter school, there are lots of charter options in Los Angeles County.
That may not even be in the districts that the students reside in, but may be accessible to them. So LA County Office of Education also is ready to help place families in the appropriate in the appropriate educational options and certainly those could be classrooms and classrooms.
be accessible to them, so LA County Office of Education
also is ready to help place families
in the appropriate educational options.
And certainly, those could be classroom-based,
or if they wish to stay in non-classroom-based,
there can be non-classroom-based programs found for them.
Are there any other questions or comments
from board members?
Member Glover-Woods?
Thank you.
Just a couple of clarification questions
for Director McFarland.
Could you let us know if you have received
the evidence of the Caltrans approval
that was mentioned during the presentation,
as well as do we have information or evidence
of a property that has been secured for the modulars
that were indicated for the 22-23 school year?
So no, we have not received any formal communication
as required by statute from Caltrans.
I understand that the director of the school
has communicated informally
with one of the consultants at Caltrans,
but EdCode requires Caltrans to send
the Department of Education a formal notice
of approval or disapproval within 30 days,
and we have not yet received that.
And in terms of a facility, no,
they do not have a facility already leased for next year.
We did just two days ago check with the realtor
of the lot that Dr. Johnson mentioned earlier,
and while they did have a lease with them
earlier in the school year,
that lease is no longer valid.
So as of this moment right now,
as far as we know,
they do not have a lease for the next school year,
nor do they have modulars already rented
and ready to go.
Right now that lot is a completely empty lot.
And just for the record,
that lot is in the same area
as the current facility that they're leasing,
which is a short-term lease.
So the current lease will end at the end of June,
and will have the same aeronautics requirement.
So they will still need to get a Caltrans clearance
on the new lot as well before they lease anything new,
if it's the same lot that we're thinking of.
So as of today,
they do not have a lot already leased
and ready to go for next school year.
Any further questions or discussion from the Board?
Then I see that Dr. Okoye Johnson would like to,
who's been raising her hand,
can I ask you for,
whether you have a last statement you wanna make?
Yes, ma'am, and thank you for the opportunity.
I'd like to address certain things that has been mentioned
that are not really completely accurate.
While Caltrans has now sent its official,
quote unquote, report,
Caltrans has sent an email
from the Office of Chief of Airports,
letting the CDE facility consultant,
as well as other staff,
know that the site is clear and could be used.
And we'll be sending this report within the next few days,
because of the timeframe involved
of putting all the report together to send to CDE.
So CDE has been notified officially via email
that this site is ready, that's one.
As it relates to the pledges that we received
and are continuing to receive,
because we were really pushing and fighting to stay alive,
we know that we can
and be able to retain and contain ECA
continuing past this school year.
I am not sure who CDE reached out to.
We're not dealing with routers.
We are really working directly
with the owner of the facility,
who happens at this point in time to be in Egypt,
out of the country.
And he has told ECA
that he will lead that lot to us,
that we do not need,
because having a lease involves continuing to pay them.
And he said, I understand your predicament.
I don't want you to continue to pay me,
but I want you to know that this lot is available for you
and I will work with you to make that happen.
We are not working with the routers.
So I'm not exactly sure who CDE talked to.
And then as he relates to the current site,
you saw in the video that it has been set up.
Considerable amount of time and funds
were invested in setting this up
so that CDE would come and see it.
It is ready for the students to use.
And you heard the parents.
We know that we will get more students to join us
for the rest of the year, if allowed to do so.
Thank you.
Thank you very much for your comments.
We appreciate that.
We appreciate all the callers.
Is there a motion from the Board?
Member Glover Woods.
Thank you, President Darling-Hammond.
I move that the CDE recommendation
to adopt the final decision to revoke
to also provide notice to the Eagle Collegiate Board
that replication becomes effective on March 30th
and also to direct Eagle Collegiate
to immediately begin closure procedures set forth
in their charter and the memorandum of understanding
with the State Board of Education.
Thank you.
Is there a second?
I will second.
Thank you.
Any further discussion?
All right.
Brooks, will you please call the roll for a vote?
Member Bonanca.
Aye.
President Darling-Hammond.
Yes.
Member Escobedo.
Vice President Glover Woods.
Yes.
Member Lewis.
Member McQuillan.
Aye.
Member Olken.
Abstain due to absence yesterday.
Member Orozco-Gonzalez.
Yes.
Member Petillo-Brownson.
Member Rodriguez.
Yes.
The motion passes.
Thank you.
I know it is very difficult when there are so many good
efforts underway to have to consider all of the fiduciary
aspects of running a school, but we hope that the program
that has been developed will find its way into one of the
neighboring schools and be available to students because
the work is, it goes on, even when it does not go on in a
particular site or a particular facility.
Let me, at this point, move us to item 12, which is approval
of the fiscal year 2021-22 career technical education
incentive grant allocations, including the allocation formula,
specific funding amounts and number of grant awards, the
purposes for grant fund use, and allowable and not allowable
expenditures.
And I am going to pass the ball to Pete Callis of the CDE.
And Pete, you may begin.
Good morning.
I am just loading up my slides real quick.
Okay.
Good morning, President Darlin-Hammond, State Board
members, Superintendent Thurmond and Chief Deputy
Nicely.
I am Pete Callis, the division director over the career
college transition division.
I am here to present the career technical education incentive
grant program allocations.
Also joining me is my administrator over the CDE
leadership office, Colby Franklin.
So we will begin with our presentation.
The California Department of Education recommends approval
of the round 7A of the career technical education incentive
grant program 2021-22 allocations.
So I will be doing an overview of the program, reviewing the
new allocation application requirements, and then an
example of how the allocation calculation works.
So the career technical education incentive grant
program was established as a state education economic and
workforce development program.
For grades, kindergarten through grade 12, with the knowledge
and skills necessary to provide pupils in kindergarten through
grades 12, with the knowledge and skills necessary to
transition to employment and post-secondary education.
Funding began in 2015, and it was a three-year program back
then.
It was $900 million over three years.
The first year, 2015-16, $450 million with a one-to-one
required match for LEAs.
2016-17, there were $300 million distributed with a 1-to-1.5-to-1
match required for the LEAs.
And 2017-18, it was $150 million distributed with a 2-to-1
match.
The legislature for 2018-19 made this an ongoing program for
California, with $150 million ongoing and a required 2-to-1
match for each of the LEAs.
For this current school year, for 2021-22, the funds were
doubled to $300 million as ongoing with a 2-to-1 match
required for each of the LEAs.
So for 2021, the CTIG allocation funding, CTIG is a formula-based
competitive grant program.
70% of the formula for allocation, calculation of allocations,
is based on the LEA's average daily attendance, their ADA.
30% of the formula is based on eight positive considerations.
Four of the positive considerations have a 5% weight to
them, and they include organizations managed by a joint
power authority.
Also, another one is for their unduplicated pupil count, also
high dropout rate, and high unemployment rate for their
region.
There are three positive considerations that are weighted at
2%.
One of them is for rural LEAs.
Another one is for leveraging programs such as Perkins,
California Partnership Academies, and the agriculture incentive
grant program.
And the third piece of that is for investment in CTE equipment,
facilities, and anything else related to CTE.
The third positive consideration is weighted at 4%, and that's for
collaboration, LEAs that collaborate with post-secondary
programs.
We had three funding groups.
4% of the funds were earmarked, which is approximately $12 million,
and that's designated for LEAs with average daily attendance of less
than or equal to 140 students.
8% of the funds, which is $24 million, is designated for applicants
with average daily attendance of more than 140, but less than equal
to 550.
And then 88% of the funding, which is approximately $264 million, is
designated for applicants with average daily attendance of more than
550.
For 2021-22, CTE was determined by the formula calculation or the
LEA match, and they received a lower amount of those two numbers.
Also this year, there was language added to our Ed code for the CTE
incentive grant program, which states that we cannot provide any more
funds above the formula calculation for their allocation.
So in CTIG 2021-22, round 7A, which is this current year, funds
available were approximately $300 million, and that's the amount of
funds we had for the CTE incentive grant program.
We had $300 million.
Apologize for not having it on full screen.
370 total applications were submitted.
342 of those 370 were approved, and our distribution for this round in
2021-22 is just over $240 million.
We did have remaining funds for this year of just over $59 million, so
we ran a round 2, which is round 7B, and we received a total of 40
applications.
Those are being scored currently, and we will bring those grant
allocations to the May State Board of Education.
There were some changes to this year's application program for the CTE
incentive grant.
Total funding, as I said, doubled to $300 million from $150 million.
Also this year, in previous years, the match was allowed to be encumbered
over the two-year grant timeline.
This year, the match must be encumbered during the first year of the grant.
CTE was required to post the CTE allocations at least 30 days before
submitting the list recommended new and renewal grant recipients to the
state board for review and approval.
That was posted 30 days prior, our preliminary list.
We did have to make some adjustments to ADAs for the consortiums that had
applied, so we submitted or we posted an updated list on February 28th.
Also a change in this year's application requirements was that LEAs can
include in the CTE pathways advanced placement programs that are CTE-based,
international baccalaureate programs that were CTE-based, or dual enrollment
programs that were CTE-based.
So that was new language that was added to this year's head code for CTE.
A brief example on how the calculation is run with the positive considerations
in the base.
So XYZ High School has an ADA of 1,000 students.
Their unduplicated pupil count was 900.
They're considered rural.
They had a high dropout rate, a high unemployment rate, and they did
collaborate with post-secondary programs.
So as you can see, for this school, it's above the 550 ADA, so they're part of
the larger group of the allocation applicants for the allocations.
So on average, they receive $95 for their ADA per student.
So at 1,000 students, they would have received $95,100 for their 70% base.
For rural, they received $43.12 per student, which comes out to about $43,120.
On the collaboration piece, they would get $6.20 per student.
With 1,000 students, they would get $6,200.
Unduplicated count, they would receive $6.32 per student, and that's times 900
per student, so they would receive $5,688.
For the high dropout rate, $7.75 per student, so they would receive $7,750.
And then the high unemployment rate was $13.23 per student, times 1,000 students
would be $13,230.
When you add up the base along with the positive consideration funding that they
received, their total calculation would be $171,088 for the allocation.
The LEA had put up a $220,000 match, the two-to-one match.
So in this example, truly an example, the actual allocation for high school XYZ
would be $171,088.
Now, with this example, if their total calculation had been above the $220,000
match, they would only receive their match amount.
We do not go above what their match could be.
Again, California Department of Education recommends approval of the round 7A of
the career technical education center grant program 2021 and 2022 allocations.
Any questions?
Comments?
Are there any clarifying questions for members of the board?
That was a very thorough explanation.
It's a very complicated formula when you really have to break it down and make sure
all your I's are dotted and T's are crossed.
You're a good teacher.
Thank you.
I think we can proceed.
Is there anything else you wanted to present or are we all set?
Okay.
I don't know if we were just doing clarifications.
Very good.
At this point, the phone line should be open for public comment, so we want to put that
public comment slide up.
And members of the public wishing to provide comment can do so by calling the telephone
number and using the access code provided on the slide that is shown now.
While we're waiting for members of the public to call in, I want to ask members McClellan
and Rodriguez if they have any initial comments, and then we'll see if we have any clarifying
questions, but I didn't see any yet.
So member McClellan.
Yes.
Thank you for the great presentation.
To the point, this is such an important area for our students in the state of California.
You know, when we think of CTE, we usually think of, you know, carpenters and auto mechanics
and construction technology, but we know today's CTE includes so much more, you know,
health sciences programs, engineering, entrepreneurship, theater arts, media, culinary
arts, and many, many other pathways for our students.
So I just wanted to remind folks of that, that it's the jobs of the future for our students.
I really appreciate how the formula turned out on this in terms of, you know, the weighted
acknowledgement for high unemployment areas and the rural areas, of course, and then the
collaboration, acknowledging collaboration and bringing together LEAs with our community
colleges, and that's so important, so important that people work together.
And then, of course, acknowledgement of the smaller LEAs in the formula.
I also really like that we created a second round for the 59 million that was still remaining to
create a second round for folks to apply again, especially during the pandemic when we know
folks are overwhelmed and our LEAs and our staffs are just trying to hold their own through this
school year, so that second round, I think, has been very helpful.
So thank you.
Thank you for the presentation.
Thank you so much.
And Member Rodriguez, would you like to add some comments?
Yes.
Thank you, Member McQuillin.
That was a wonderful overview because it isn't the home ec classes that we knew about in the
past, right?
You know, this is actually our students are able to see professionals in action.
They're able to mentor and model with them.
And for my community in particular, we do have such a high unemployment rate.
And I see how our CTE pathways at my high school and throughout our community is producing
students who are learning about culinary arts, who are becoming dental hygienists.
They graduate and they are on their path to go into a career.
And these are a lot of the programs that change the poverty that sometimes our students, you know,
that path, right?
They're able to graduate with confidence.
They go into deep learning with especially using, you know, some of the schools that employ the
methods of linked learning.
It's very powerful to see what we see we can become.
And it makes me excited when I see my students transform from being disconnected from school to
actually having hope that they found a career that they can follow and enrich their lives and their
families and our community.
So I really appreciate this.
And the second round.
And I'm excited to see what the second round is going to look like.
Thank you.
Terrific.
Are there any other clarifying questions before we go to public comment?
Seeing none, we will see if we have some callers in the queue.
We have four callers in the queue.
I will open the phone lines now.
Thank you.
Good morning.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Good morning.
Kyle on behalf of the CTA coalition, an organization comprised of 14 regional programs and centers to
deliver CTA school districts in California.
Our coalition was very supportive of increasing the ongoing CTA funding for $150 to $300 million in
the 2122 state budget act.
However, despite the significant increase, many of our members were funded below their match request for
2122.
While we understand the current methodology utilized by CDE caps grantee awards at the formula
eligibility amount, this nonstatutory formula has also led to a remaining balance of over $59 million.
Rather than risk CTA funds returning back to the state, we believe that CDE could allow 2122
applicants that are proposed to be funded below their match level access to the remaining dollars.
There is no reason for the funds to go unspent when high quality CTA providers have the capacity to
invest these resources in successful programs.
Our coalition also requests that the CTA allocations and methodology be made available earlier in the
fiscal year.
CTA recipients rely on these funds to sustain and grow existing programs and a possible task when
recipients do not know until late in the fiscal year whether or not they will be receiving the funds.
For these reasons, we believe CDE should commit to an annual schedule for application approval and
distribution.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Good morning.
President, members of the board.
On behalf of the association of career and college readiness organizations, I would like to associate
myself with the comments of Mr. Highland.
And I would just add that while we are very excited to have this long anticipated funding go out,
there is still confusion in the field over process and so forth.
We know you're working out the keys.
So we look forward to working with CDE and the state board to have a more consistent and stable process
and hopefully get the funds out earlier because we know we have students ready to learn.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Hi.
Good morning.
President Darwin-Hammond and members of the board.
This is Manuel Buenrostro with California Together.
And I'm calling in reference to the second round of applications.
We recommend adding to the eight criteria for positive consideration.
A priority in education with an incentive for teacher preparation programs for high-need fields,
including bilingual teachers, CDE programs.
This funding can be the beginning of creating a bilingual teacher pipeline in high school
and also pipelines for other high-need areas.
This would attract students who are bilingual and working towards attaining the state's dual
bi-literacy upon graduation to pursue their credential.
And there's an indication of the need for this.
So I'm calling in reference to the second round of applications.
We recommend adding to the eight criteria for positive consideration.
A priority in education with an incentive for teacher preparation programs for high-need fields,
including bilingual teachers, CDE programs.
This funding can be the beginning of creating a bilingual teacher pipeline in high school
and also pipelines for other high-need areas.
This would attract students who are bilingual and working towards attaining the state's dual
bi-literacy upon graduation to pursue their credential.
And there's an indication of the need for this.
We look at much of the data from CCTC and the need for more teachers in these high-need fields.
Thank you again, and have a great rest of your meeting.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Good morning, Dr. Darlene Hammond and board members.
Diana Vu on behalf of the Association of California School Administrators.
Acts that request CDE make the preliminary allocations are available.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Good morning, Dr. Darlene Hammond and board members.
We look at much of the data from CCTC and the need for more teachers in these high-need fields.
And there's an indication of the need for more teachers in these high-need fields.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Your time starts.
Your time starts right now.
Action requests of CDE prendre allocation methodology.
At the same time, release the preliminary allocation in conjunction with methodology is not only best practice but is often the best option for transparency.
Thank you.
Caller ending in 1-0-0-0, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Okay.
It looks like that concludes public comment for item number 12.
All right.
Thank you very much.
So we are now open for discussion from the board.
I do want to make one note.
There was a caller who talked about launching teaching academies or teaching pathways.
And there is a proposal in the January budget from the governor's office to do precisely
that, to put $1.8 billion towards pathways that would include STEM pathways, computer
science pathways, green technology pathways, and teaching pathways.
So hopefully we will be able to be talking about and looking at those sometime in the
near future.
I see a hand up.
It came and it went.
Member Olken, did you have your hand up for a second?
Okay.
The Zoom board also shifted on me.
So I saw the hand and then the Zoom shifted.
Member Benaka, please go ahead.
Yes, thank you.
I just really want to...
I think...
You may be freezing on us.
Is it working?
Okay.
Try again.
Why don't you go back to the beginning?
Hopefully it's working now.
It is now.
It is.
All right.
I just want to applaud the efforts in developing this formula and applaud that and just thank
Peter for the presentation.
And I also want to say that I think that CTE is not only practical in the sense that it
helps prepare students for careers, but I think just the fact that students are able
to focus on their passions and develop that into something that they can do for a living
is just such an incredible opportunity for students.
And I also think that it really helps students engage with what they're doing at school.
And then also in the formula, I really appreciate the weight of the unduplicated pupil count,
the high dropout rate and the high employment rate that is considered when giving out these
grants.
And so, yeah, I just really applaud these efforts and I'm really glad that we're working
on this.
Any other comments or questions?
I do want to clarify, Pete, that my understanding is that by statute we're not permitted to
fund up to the match.
We have to fund to the formula.
Is that right?
And you're on mute.
You're talking to yourself on mute.
Yeah, in the past, they've been able to do some things with the formula to add share
funding to them to get them closer to the match.
There is actually language that was added this year that does not allow us to do that.
So that's very clear in the language now that they either get their calculated amount or
if it goes beyond that, they only get their match.
Okay.
Member McQuillin.
Yeah, just to follow up related to the caller who called in asking for an addition to support,
I think, bilingual teachers and what you mentioned, Chairperson, that the one billion plus that's
in the proposed governor's, would this include supporting bilingual teacher development?
It would.
Yeah.
So I'm excited for the possibilities that we could start to address our teacher needs
and shortages by getting kids excited about teaching in high school.
I think Member Glover-Woods has a hand up.
Yes, thank you.
Just wanted to ask a quick question around the timeline for the allocations because we're
looking at allocations, I believe, and Pete, correct me if I'm wrong, for the 21-22 school
year, which will be coming to a close in a couple of months.
Is that the typical timeline that we use and are the awardees required to expend these
funds within the 21-22 school year?
That's my first question or first and second.
So our goal was to get them out sooner and we had all the applications in and scored.
But once the trailer bill language came out with new requirements, we had to make a shift
and add two addendums to the application process, which delayed us in getting the allocations
processed sooner.
If there are no changes in language for this coming school year, we should have them to
the board by no later than a November board meeting for approval.
That's our goal.
And if we can do it by September, that would be even better for us to answer the second
part of your question.
They have until December 2023 to expend these funds.
Thank you.
Are there any other questions or comments from members of the board?
And if there are not, I will invite a motion.
Do we have a motion?
Yes.
Can we get the screen back up?
The recommendation?
Oh, yes.
Absolutely.
Thank you.
And thank you for a wonderful presentation.
Very complete.
Thank you.
So I move that the state board follow the recommendation that the CDE has provided here.
All right.
Do we have a second?
Member McQuillan, did I see you shaking your hand?
Okay.
I second that motion.
Thank you very much.
Any further discussion?
Brooks, can you call the roll for a vote?
Member Bonacca?
Aye.
President Darlin-Hammond?
Member Escobedo?
Yes.
Vice President Glover-Woods?
Member Lewis?
Yes.
Member McQuillan?
Vice President Bonacca?
Aye.
Yes.
Vice President Bonacca?
Aye.
Yes.
Vice President Bonacca?
Aye.
weddings?
Yes.
The motion carries unanimously.
Thank youied and thank you, Pete.
We''re now going to take a break for about 10 minutes.
It is 958.
Let''s be generous and go until 1010.
See you back at 10 10 don't don't leave the meeting. Just turn off your video and your mic
We're going to resume and Brooks, will you please call the roll to reestablish the quorum member Bonanca
Here president Darlin Hammond here number Escobedo
Here vice president Glover Woods
Here number Lewis
As it number McQuillan
Here number Olken
Here number Roscoe Gonzalez
Here number Petillo Brownson
Here number Rodriguez
Here everyone's present. We have a quorum
Okay
So the public comment slide has been up and we are going to take our waiver consent calendar
Which includes waiver items w1 through 8
The comment line has been open since before the break. So we'll go ahead and take public comment right away
Are there any public comments for w1 through 8? There are no colors on the queue for public comment
All right
Given that there's no other public comment. I'll ask for a motion on waivers w1 through 8. Do I have a motion?
So moved. Thank you. Do I have a second?
Second. Thank you. I will now hold a roll call vote. Brooks, can you please call the roll?
Member Bonanca
Aye
President Darlin Hammond
Number Escobedo
Aye
Vice President Glover Woods
Yes
Number Lewis
Number McQuillan
Yes
Number Olken
Member Roscoe-Gonzalez
Aye
Member Petillo-Brownson
Yes
Member Rodriguez
Motion carries unanimously
All right
I'm now going to reopen item one to take action on the preliminary report of actions of draft January
2022 meeting minutes and to report on our liaison assignment
and so we
While we're waiting for any
Members of the public to call in we filled the public comment slide up. Do I have a motion?
From board member to approve the January 2022 state board of education draft preliminary report of action meeting minutes
So moved
Second. Do I have a second? Second. Thank you. Are there any public comments?
There are no callers for public comments
Okay, uh, so at that
At this that moment then we just need to see uh, if there's any further further discussion
I'm seeing none
uh
and
This time we're going to raise our hands in the participant panel of the zoom
So brooks can keep track of raised hands. I don't know. I guess that's if you have a comment
You don't have a comment
Uh, that was in my script. We'll we'll now hold a roll call vote brooks. Please call the roll
member von anka
Hi
President darlin hammed
Yes
member eskabelo
Yes vice president. Glover woods
Yes
member lewis
abstain
member mcquillin
Yes
Member oaken
abstain
member arosco gonzalez
member patillo brownson
Not abstaining and yes
Thank you for that clarity. Uh member. Rodriguez. Yes
Motion carries
All right, that was easy
Um now I want to invite the state board members to report on any liaison activities that are not related to any items on our
March agenda
Um, and although I will not call on our new board members today for that purpose at the end of our liaison reports
I will call on them if they have other comments and say a few words about them
So we'll start with um student member ron anka
Thank you president darlin hammed
To begin with in january
I attended a discussion hosted by the california student board member association or csbma
About the 2022 revision of the state math framework
And I was able to hear a multitude of opinions and perspectives on the proposed
framework from student board members through throughout the state and even perspectives from adults like math professors and advocates and of course
I was diligently taking notes because I know that we are set to take action
On this framework in our july meeting
And then I also attended a national student board member association meeting where I was able to learn
From the experiences and the insights of student board members throughout the nation
And I really love to hear about how they all approach hearing student voice, which is of course really important to student board members
Um, and so in that same vein i'm currently working on organizing statewide virtual student forums so that I can hear
Input from students throughout the state about the issues that they're passionate about and the issues that they care about most
And then i'm also starting to work with the california association of student councils or cask
To plan more ways that the student board member on the state board or me this year
Um can increase their collaboration with cask moving forward whether that be through hosting
student town halls or giving reports at
cask conferences on statewide
Updates and things of that nature
And so i'm looking forward to that
And then finally in terms of the mask mandate being lifted just in time for school on monday
I want to remind students to be respectful of other people's decisions
I know that i've already seen discussions in my school about it and students are
Or some students I should say are already making fun of other students for their decisions of whether or not to wear a mask
Um, and more often than not I see that students that are choosing to continue to wear their masks are
Are being poked fun at and made fun of a bit more
which is really
Mask wearing is still strongly recommended
But at the end of the day once the mandate is lifted, we need to be respectful of each other's choices
And that concludes my liaison report
Thank you, and thank you for that very important, um comment and reminder. We really appreciate that
members cabello
Yes as part of being a liaison for wested wested has been
very busy in in gearing up for
the
2022 just last week
um air was part of a
the keynote at
address with
With I mean wested was part of a keynote address, uh with air
At the national association of school principals in dc
Um, it gathered many of the elementary and middle school leaders across the country
Um, and they highlighted a real interesting study. It was a study on
Um entitled leaders we need
Now research series and
They conducted wested conducted. Um 36 focus groups with 188 principals
across the nation and
there were three
Tenants that I would love to bring up one was um
That during this time there was some real specific school innovations and new perspectives
that have been
Created or discovered, you know from this
covid time
and basically some of the learnings specifically in how
The use of remote instructional technology helped in some cases obviously supplement and extend learning
And and the importance of flexible staffing as well and and then
A second finding was really the evolution of the principalship, especially during this
Pandemic year that will continue on will continue
In the sense of crisis management and the importance of communicating effectively, especially in in in the highly
politicized
local community and
the importance of balancing
Vocal and ardent groups and then and then the third finding is is the finding on
focus on policy
and I
you know as I read through some of the recommendations i'm so proud of being part of
a cde because many of the recommendations such as
You know creating um metrics to capture how well schools are supporting the whole whole child and funding for
In school mental and and physical health support how we're doing this. I mean, it's
It's heartwarming to see
That uh, some of this research is being applied in california
and something that you may be interested in is
a
covid-19 accelerated learning recovery plan has been created by uh west ed
You could go onto their site and find their their resources. It focused on
equitable outcomes from underserved students
Uh research to improve strategy and decision making
some real focus on instructional support content focus instructional support and
More focus on safe and healthy conditions for improved learning
Thank you, that's the end of my report terrific that's really interesting
Uh, thank you. Um, I think our next person is vice president glover once
Thank you, um, the majority of my liaison assignments were covered in this month's
um agenda items
I the only part that I would add is I had an opportunity to
um observe the instructional quality commission meeting that took place in january and they took action forward to
Uh put together their subject matter committees as well as electing their chairs and co-chairs
Co-chairs and the iqc, um is
Up and ready for the business that will be coming before them in the future
Thank you
terrific
Um member mcclellan
Thank you not a whole lot to report, uh, we are
waiting for the uh
the joint commission on career technical education to
Sort of find a date that works. We've had to cancel the past couple. I think we're
Waiting for additional board members to be seated
And the tentative date for the next joint
committee
Is march 25th
and that's where uh members of our state board of education pulled together with the members of the
community colleges of california
Board members on that committee so aiming for march 25th if that works
I also want to report that um
cd has selected uh, two sites to work on the
model american indian curriculum for california
and uh, those two sites are
San diego county office of education and humble county office of education were selected
To develop and pull together the model curriculum
On, uh native american studies for california. We're happy about that
It's kind of up in here in my neck of the woods humble del lorde area at least they call it behind the redwood curtain
Um, there was only 300 000 allocated for that work between the two sites
So it's a little underfunded. So we're hoping that additional funds will be added to that effort, but that's very good news. So
That's all I have to say. Thank you
All right. Thank you very much. Uh, that's really good news about the curriculum getting rolling. Uh,
that's
historic
Member patil bronson
Uh, good morning. I I wanted to highlight a couple of meetings, um that
Focused on that connection between the early years
early learning pre-k tk up to the third grade
Timeframe, um, I think I had mentioned previously that there is a upk
kitchen cabinet being convened, um
by a number of state leaders and led by sarah neville morgan, uh very ably
In terms of really shining a light on the importance of the universal tk rollout
i've also been in conversation with a number of school districts who are
very busily getting ready for the new
school year and thinking about both what it takes to communicate through the ranks of school districts
the value proposition that transitional kindergarten and upk universal pre-k offer
in terms of preparation for
K to 12 success, um, and also for eliminating and preventing the achievement gap
um, I think um
That communication challenge is one side on one
in terms of communications to leas
And then of course there is the broader set of communications that will be necessary to make sure that families understand what?
a meaningful offering is being
Made available in california because it really is unprecedented and it's excited also to be in conversations with leaders from other states
Who are watching california and and cheering us on to get this right?
um, there's also been a number of recent meetings and i've been doing these more in southern california to
Look at what is the pipeline for the 24 unit?
requirement, um and
What both districts can offer in-house in terms of those necessary
Sort of educational units, but also what partnerships can be had with higher ed?
Related to that, I think
hearing and now seeing sort of the trickle of
information in terms of assessments as to where
Where we have lost ground and where there are opportunities to really accelerate?
both
Gains, but also just ongoing progress and third grade reading
the the trailer bill language
Articulating that some of the community schools funding can be used for reading specialists
As well as literacy coaches, I think is really exciting
as well as the budget the governor's budget proposal, uh for
The 500 million to focus on that to make sure that kids by third grade are where we need them to be so that the rest
Of their their k-12 trajectory is about
Learning beyond but they have that foundation squarely under their belt
It's been an interesting process of learning
how few
programs can offer
the reading specialist credential on an expedited basis because
Obviously the emergency is now and we want to make sure that kids have access
to these
specialty
Especially trained teachers and adults who can help them accelerate
Their learning and reading progress as quickly as possible
And then the last thing i'll just say which is more on the wraparound services just
Hearing california highlighted for the cali itc work for working families
and again recognizing that
students children live in the context of families and however
There are a whole set of available resources
for their families to be well and economically secure matter and the starting to to
Track some of the partnerships that are happening with leas to actually promote some of these offerings
So that families can be well as their children are on their own wellness journeys in schools
And that concludes my report
Terrific. Thank you
So many exciting things happening that are getting off the ground right now. It's wonderful to hear all of the ways in which
People are experiencing them member rodriguez
Yes, thank you. Um president charlene hammon
So
First of all, I want to start out. I I have three reports. One of them is uh,
tamo the uh, and the regional el specialist the other
Uh, sisa some california summer school for the arts
And then lastly ctc
But one of the things that I want to acknowledge and recognize that in the last two years
We have all
Worked in ways that we never imagined doing something that we
Didn't really weren't prepared and really didn't know how to do
And you know starting
With the leadership at the state level, uh, you know our governor setting the example
Or support from the state legislature
and
These last meetings that I attended i'm just so optimistic about seeing this
progress and successes and upward trends, uh, and again, especially during you know as we're
Literally building the plane while we're flying it and it just goes to show
how
strong and creative and innovative
and adaptable, uh we are
In meeting the needs of our of our students and our teachers
And you know when i'm talking about adaptability i'm talking about parents students the bodies that were all
Uh, you know that we all sit on whether it's as policy makers or liaisons
So I just really want to acknowledge that and thank you to everyone who has modeled this california way attitude
So i'll start with uh tamo and for
Um, the new members in the public, uh, i'll
Just, you know talk a little bit about the acronym. It's technical assistance and monitoring office
Uh on wednesday, march 2nd tamo hosted the regional el
Specialists and what a powerful and insight is inspiring meeting it was
There's a lot to celebrate and first i'd like to acknowledge the leadership of therese hawk
um
Jake, uh, jakey gula gula
I'm sorry. He goes by gq
And evan tiet
The support that they have provided county offices and the regional
El specialist is at the core of the success that was shared at this meeting. Um, yes, they have challenges ahead
Uh, one of the members of the team has taken a job within another department
And they still have a lot of the important work to do conducting the reviews for the al caps
Um, and there were a few of the uh, ewig partners ewig educator workforce investment grant
Shared about some of the highlights that they have experienced in the last
Um in the last couple of years
Uh, first dr. Ana castro from cave and m cap shared some some of these
Uh progresses they've held two statewide summits
um
The m cap team meets monthly. They have delivered training to para educators
Language training because they have requested
To know more and so that's exciting right, you know for the para educators to receive
Some of these powerful programs that they've put together nine asynchronous academies
And um, very exciting they've launched parent innovation programs
Where they have served the parents helping them work closely with their children at home
And supporting them with technology platforms. They're also working to improve the bilingual teacher preparation programs
Next dr magali lavadans her name came up yesterday
With el rise and lmu and her team have done some vigorous work
With english learner master plan playbook, which by the way, it's available for download
And it's just a fantastic
Resource for anybody working with the all students whether it's you know, the leadership at the lea or teachers in the classroom
Para professionals
I suggest downloading it and planning accordingly the team has created has worked to create
Clarity across the state they have far exceeded their original goal and have worked with
45 county offices across california and have reached over 500 participants
They're working with colleagues to create visionary policies patricia carlin of s, san diego county office of education
Shared that she has used the playbook
and has created a google doc that
Um alias can use as a template and leave their examples and this is a great
Um a great way to highlight the collaboration and sharing best practices
Uh, then a regional recap the um the regional, uh
leads
Presented they talked about they had five minutes to talk about
The successes they were having and then some of the challenges that they were facing
And generally, uh, some of the successes is the work around parent support, uh, especially talking about trauma
and um, you know resilience being able to understand some of the barriers, uh that students are facing
And giving the parents access
Uh to support their their children at home some of the barriers or are some of the barriers that we have seen
uh, right the lack of data just because of uh, you know our
Our testing changes in in because of the pandemic
And for reclassification purposes and also just a sense of general exhaustion because of the plates that people are juggling
um
One of the things that gq said
Is that um, you know, the goal is for the alias to avoid solely a compliance centered
Uh model and uh, you know when he's conducted reviews
Uh, oftentimes alias are using instruments that are three or four or even 10 years old and so
He's really trying to get into a service centered rather than a compliance centered model
And I I really like
You know that going into into the future that way
Um next with um ctc
Um, many of the members of the commission and executive director sandy shared touching anecdotes and tributes and um,
very heartfelt tributes to assembly member and state senator gary hart who passed away in january and who was uh,
such a big part of uh ctc
and you know a lot of the a lot of the changes that have had happened within the
Last couple of decades
Um
and the work continues with the two design teams of ece early childhood education experts
advising the commission on the development
of both the ece
Teacher performance assessments and the new program called quality peer review process
Um, they're continuing to move the initial developmental work to the pilot testing
Um, and which will happen around late spring 2022
The four ece pilots are continuing to support implementation of this transformative work
Moving toward the tpe aligned curriculum and instruction within ece preparation programs as well as towards supporting the programs
to complete a self-analysis regarding how close they are to meeting the commission's adopted
Program guidelines that address quality prep for the ec workforce
Um
next there was a
report on the residency programs
The ct staff developed a timeline timeline
For the request for applications for the new teacher residency grant competitions authorized by assembly bill 130
Um
Findings from the second year of the teacher residency program during a global pandemic were presented at the meeting
The highlights were centered around enrollment completion and hiring findings from an analysis of data collected
About the first two cohorts and residents
Recommendations, uh from a newly released teach brief teacher residency programs in california financial
Sustainability challenges and opportunities include the following
Grantee programs have made progress toward key outcomes
challenging conditions and
Including or included
They highlight the importance of the residencies
Their plans for future sustainability
um
the
Let's see grant funding remains available
For the encumbrance through june 30th 2023 a final report is due from the commission
Uh, probably in december
2022 because it will uh, it'll be for the policy committees and state legislator. So once we that is complete
I will return with a report
And next there was a
a very
Strong and
robust conversation
about ed tpas
they're
You know one of the questions that that
commissioners and
people from the public
Would like to see addressed in further research and further studies
Is um, you know, what is it? Is it the context about ed tpa?
That seems to be tough for teachers of color
Uh to pass the performance assessments
There, uh, you know while there were some people that were calling in and saying we'd like to see more evidence
um, they're
The thought is that context matters, right? Um, and so
There are a few studies that uh, you know are showing how powerful the tpas are
for teachers that they feel prepared when they go into the classroom and
some of the public and some of the commissioners would like to look into those studies a little bit more and answer some of
the questions of
Is there a barrier? What is it and how can we?
uh work to make sure that we
Uh that that this isn't
A gatekeeper for teachers of color to come into the profession
um there
Uh, the student liaison
Said that you know, she has found that the ed tpa
She was actually going through it at the time that the meeting was happening
And how much she appreciated the reflective practice, which is what the ed tpa intended
Uh, you know, she said she had you know had to question like why she did this the focus of equity, right?
Which was another intention of the ed tpa
And how prepared she felt?
To confront the challenges of the classroom
um, uh, it was it was interesting because
a commissioner who used to be one of the public members representing, um,
Uh sisa
Talked about how when the ntpas were first adopted he was a little bit reluctant. He thought it was another
uh bureaucratic hurdle and as a human resource employer
And this is commissioner simmons said that he has noticed how well prepared the teachers who?
Uh are with the ntpas how how ready they are to handle the challenges, um ahead of them
So it was a very interesting discussion and there will be more on that
Executive director sandy
uh, you know said that uh, we'll bring it back in a very transparent way to reflect and to
answer
the initial question of
The purpose and how to make sure that uh, they can confront the barriers that they're seeing especially when it comes to teachers of color
And then lastly
Another acronym sisa not sisa, uh, the california state summer school for the arts
And this is for the new members
If you're not familiar a rigorous profession, uh pre-professional
Month-long training program in the visual and performing arts creative writing animation
And film for talented artists of high school age
Sisa provides a supportive environment in which students own
Acquired skills and explore new techniques and ideas for an intense and exciting learning experience
The school was created by the california legislature and held its first session in 1987
Uh, and the purpose is to provide a training ground for future artists who wish to pursue careers in the arts
And entertainment entertainment industries in california
Applications for summer school have closed with so this is the update
Um with a thousand applicants and that is a big deal because that signifies an upward
Trend there have been a couple of difficult years and sisa is definitely recovering
Um, the 2022 application deadline was monday. It's past monday at 6 pm
And as always it was a rush to the finish with 70 percent of the applicants arriving within the last 48 hours of the deadline
Applicants are up from last year and this is really good
But they have not reached pre-pandemic levels
This year the board decided
to limit
The program to only students from california because of covid if somebody would contract
Would be covid positive
If they're, you know from france or china
how will they
you know be
as
Be sent home if they're covid positive
so
Only california students applied this year
But last year there were
895 applications
The overall applications have uh
Were started steadily declining since their peak of 2017
But the uptick this year is encouraging visual arts and writing are under the six-year average
The other departments have larger decreases including animation, which is the most competitive program historically
Um the increased tuition may also have been a factor
Um executive director matt gallagher will be researching the data further and report back soon on race ethnicity
stance
Percentage of the applicants with financial aid and more so stay tuned and thank you always so much for your support
Thank you
um
I will just piggyback on a couple of the reports that have been made to note that
Uh
As several folks have said tk is rolling out across the state
There's a lot of work going on on the workforce question
the ctc is
Going to be approving the requirements for an early childhood credential
Shortly and that will be accessible not only through the multiple
subjects
Pathway where teachers can add 24 units but also for early childhood educators or people trained in early childhood
to come in
and be
credentialed for
To build on what they've already accomplished in their permits
And then to be credentialed for early childhood from age three through I think they're calling it three through three age three through grade three
Is I think the strategy that they're pursuing?
So I wanted to be sure that people understand particularly those who are trying to think about how to staff tk programs
There's also going to be some guidance coming out shortly that will provide guidance for how
in the short run
districts and
County offices that are involved in this can staff up from multiple sources of supply
there are
30 000 folks in the assist in the early childhood system who have the bachelor's degree and most of the
Requirements for a credential already and then of course folks from the elementary school
Side of the equation as well
And then the other thing I just wanted to note building on
member patio brownson's
comments about literacy coaches and reading specialists those
That is a proposal in the january budget
for 500 million dollars to help tiny districts to
To develop and extend their reading programs with
literacy coaches who are
Trained there will be a training program attached and reading specialists who can work one-on-one in small groups with kids there has there's
extraordinary
Data available about the impacts of high intensity high intensity tutoring for rapidly
Enabling students to regain ground both in math and english language arts
We have another
Grant proposal going out to provide training for those tutors
in reading and english language arts who use and
Mathematics who use a vetted
highly
Effective curriculum and strategies to
Help students
Really catch up quickly and so I want people to be aware that that is
Going on there will be grants issued for
several county offices in in the coming days or weeks, it's
imminent to
Begin providing that kind of training
for
strategies for learning acceleration that can be used in multi-tiered systems of support
Can be used in regular classrooms and can be used in the after school and summer school
Context where we have new resources going out
So lots going on all across the state
I do want to give our new board members an opportunity to say a few words
We needed when you first arrived to get to a closed session meeting which you
Had a chance to participate in but we didn't have a chance to say very much about you or hear very much from you
So I just wanted to take this opportunity for at least a brief introduction
To each of you. I'm going to start with brenda because she's in the middle of the alphabet and
You know, we sometimes start at the end we start sometimes start at the beginning we hardly ever start in the middle
And if you ever play bidwist some people will know bidwist goes uptown and downtown
But some people want to create a form of bidwist that starts in the middle of the deck of cards
Uh, dr brenda lewis, uh, you retired as an associate superintendent, I think from the pern high school district
um, she uh
Got her start with a master's degree in physical education and as a doctorate in organizational leadership
She led the instruction division, uh curriculum and instruction professional development student supports and discipline
Athletics and activities assessment and accountability
So she's very familiar with our basket of work here at the state board local control accountability plan
equity and inclusion and two district level student advisory councils
She was also the grand marshal of the black american history month parade in bakersfield, which I would have loved to have seen
and uh has uh
Has a long uh
Career and experience in bakersfield
So we want to welcome you to the board and brenda if you have some things you'd like to share we would love to
Hear your thoughts
Thank you president darlin hammon and you know, i'll start by saying yesterday in my introductory comments
I said I was excited and honored to be a part of this
This board and I want you to know that after yesterday and today i'm still excited. Okay, that hasn't left me
So
No, I I truly I mean you've given my background. Um
uh been I was at the district for 33 years and uh again had the opportunity to participate in a lot of different areas or
A lot of different hats and administration along the way
And I I will say yesterday and so far today it has it's been a rewarding experience. I
I admire each of you for you know
The time that you've been on this board and continuing on the board because we cover a lot of agenda items a lot of issues coming from
uh different uh
topics in different directions and have to take into consideration
statute and law and what's best for kids on the school site and also
A couple of them I will say tug at your heartstrings over the last couple of days
but we you know, we have to to to do what's best in the overall big picture for students and
Um, you know my comments may go everywhere, but I love rana
I love the fact that there's a student on this board
I just left the district and wasn't able to serve with the student
We just put a student on the the board in the district that I left but
Some of the things I hear and all of the things that are going on behind the scenes with the members
Uh different groups that they are working with or committees
Um, it's it's a lot of work and i'm ready to dive in
wherever needed to enroll up my sleeves and get started
to provide what knowledge that I can and expertise that I can bring to the board and to help in any way possible and
Again, just looking forward to the work that we have ahead of us and being a contributor
Um to to our work and a good teammate
To my fellow board members and again rana, I can't say enough about students
I love mentoring. I love working with students and to see you and just hear you the last couple of days
I mean if if if we would if president darling ham and would have introduced you as a student
I think someone would have thought you were a staff member somewhere by your comment in your intellect. So
Thank you for that and a student voice is so important. So good luck
With your efforts and bringing together that virtual meeting
Statewide to bring students together because for so long it was just the adults in the room
but the students add a great voice a great perspective of
To a lot of issues and it keeps us on our toes. So thank you for that and to my fellow board members
I'm just looking forward to the work we have ahead of us. Thank you. Terrific. Thank you
And all of the new board members know that they will be
Um having the opportunity to take up their liaison assignments
Shortly, so we'll be hearing more from you in that capacity by next time
I'm going to go to gabriela roscoe gonzalez
That goes either way in the alphabet depending on which name you use
She is an elementary school teacher and has taught in montobello unified school district for over 20 years
She's taught kindergarten through sixth grade. So she's gone
Up and down the the ladder with the kids and knows how they develop at every age and stage
She is a common core standards expert a curriculum and assessment writer master teacher and mentor
In addition, she's a teacher leader for the instructional leadership core, which is a wonderful
a group of a couple of hundred teachers across the state
who have been helping us with the
Uh shifts in instructional practice associated with the common core state standards
And have been doing just incredible work. I had the opportunity to participate in an evaluation of the program and the
Evaluation comments from other teachers about having teachers in their districts leading them through this process. We're so positive
And so inspiring. She's a national presenter on common core instructional hips and teacher leadership
And she's also a blogger and she writes about teaching strategies curriculum and educational resources
So for those of us who like to geek out on those topics, there's a new blog for us to find
Gabriela, would you like to say a couple of words?
Yes, thank you. Um again really excited just like member lewis about being part of this board
I'm very fortunate to have a voice as an elementary school teacher. I've
12 second grade for 12 years now and it really
I think of
Miss bronz and how you mentioned about reading literacy and how important for um to support
As our students are in that developmental stage of learning to read and this whole two days has been a whirlwind but i've
Really had several items that I know that i'm really passionate about
I mean, I think about item number two and assessments. I started
The work with common core when it was first introduced in 2010 and
As an assessment writer and item reviewer. I really think that I can bring a voice to
Those topics as they present to the board
I also think about item six and how about job quality and safe safety and and just workplaces and
Adult education family literacy all programs that I've worked really closely with in my district and I've bought into
When I work with ilc and work my collaboration with the california teachers association and building partnerships with families
Some of the things that i've done in our local districts and downing and montobello and in the la area is
Really bringing parent connections into the classroom and building those partnerships with students. So
rana, I also think about how important it is to have student voice and
And really build those communities of learners where
We collaborate as educators with not only the community with parents and and including student voice
Continuously and everything that we do in education how that impact is
Is just enormous in our school district. So
Just learning i'm a listener right now and just kind of taking it all in
But I know that I can contribute as time goes on. I just want to make sure that I
I have the right pockets to to insert my thoughts into but thank you for this opportunity and i'm excited to collaborate
terrific and sharon olken
Sharon has been the executive director of gateway public schools in san francisco
Which is a middle and a high school?
that were really initially founded by
parents of students with disabilities
To create an inclusive and effective learning environment
She's been there for more than 20 years as a teacher a school leader and a school founder
I've learned a lot from Sharon
She is a graduate of the stanford teacher education program who we have tapped many times for advice and counsel
on special education needs and on a variety of other things
she
Helps the students discover their unique potential what they love the impact they help to make on their communities in this very diverse
student community
She recently founded everyday leadership a website dedicated to providing models of positive leadership and helping others cultivate their power in their voice
Sharon
Thank you president darling hammond and
I can't tell you how much i've learned from you over the years, so i'm
honored and flattered that you turned that around on me and
I just want to say i'm so
Humbled to be on this board with you all and to when you when you said yesterday we
Are serving 6.2 million students in the state of california
Um, I got butterflies in my stomach, um, because that is such a
Exciting and huge responsibility and one I feel
Just really honored to be able to um be part of I
Those of those who know me at gateway know that um
I try my best to speak without acronyms as much as possible and
Keep sort of the intent of what we're doing
front and center, which is for me all about
the well-being and sense of
agency of our students
um
So I have a lot of learning to do about the acronyms. I'm keeping a i'm keeping a running list
But what i've learned so far in just the brief time i've been here is
um
All those acronyms if you get past
Trying to figure out
Trying to remember what they are. They're all doing amazing work. That's making
um
Our school's better places for our students first and foremost, but also for our staff
um and
It's it's really um
Well, i've i've been a strong believer in the importance of
The this the local context, you know the importance when I first got in education
I thought I wanted to do education policy work and then when I became a teacher
It's like no the real work happens in the classroom
And i've stayed as close as I can to kids
Throughout my career. Um
But even in the the short time i've been here mostly listening
I can see that the marriage of really good policy and really good schools
Is how you make major change for kids. Um, and so i'm
excited to be on this team and learning from you all and um, hopefully
Helping us do more good for our young people who are going to help us make our state and
The world a better place because we know there's a lot of work to do so
Indeed there is and thank you. We're thrilled to have all of you join us and doing that work
Um, and uh, we are now ready to take up our last item which is item 13
General public comment public comment is invited on any matter not included in the printed agenda
I think we want to see the comment. There we go
uh
We'll open the phone line for the public comment queue and members of the public wishing to provide comment may do so by calling the number
Shown on the public comment slide and using the access that is shown there
Uh, we remind you to turn down the volume of your computer
Or if you're listening to the live webcast to avoid background echoes
Uh, are there any public comments?
There are no public comments for for item 13
We understand that there's a little bit of a lag in the feed so maybe we just give 30 more seconds as a lag
We'll do a little wait time
Okay
Okay, and still no more colors feel free to go ahead thank you all right I
Hereby adjourn our march 2022 state board meeting at 1101 am
Thank you, and I look forward to seeing you at our may meeting and if we're fortunate we may be in person
Take care
Thank you everyone and welcome new members so happy to have you here
Thank you pleasure
Welcome welcome